[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday November 1st I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
self-driving Trucking Company too simple
has been grappling with a number of
challenges in recent months
its stock price is down 90 for the year
and according to exclusive wsj reporting
the FBI Securities and Exchange
Commission and the committee on foreign
investment in the U.S are looking into
whether the company improperly financed
and transferred technology to a Chinese
startup on Monday a day after the Wall
Street Journal reported on the
investigations into the company the
board of too simple announced it had
fired its chief executive and co-founder
shouty Howe so what happens next for too
simple which had been seen as the leader
in the self-driving Trucking sector
joining us to discuss this is our
venture capital and startups reporter
Heather Somerville hi Heather thanks for
coming back on the show Hey Zoe Heather
it feels like there's a lot of moving
parts to this story so I just want to
take a second to break some of those
down there are two companies that are at
the heart of this too simple and a
Chinese startup called hydron what are
the connections between the two
the connections are in the founders of
these two companies so too simple was
founded in 2015 by mochen and shouty
Howe they have run the company for the
most part these last several years in
2021 this other company emerged called
hydron which says it is developing
hydrogen-powered self-driving trucks and
has most of its operations in China and
the founder and head of it is mochen who
as I mentioned is also the co-founder of
too simple
in addition to hydron has said that too
simple is its first and so far as we can
tell only customer and that too simple
has pledged to buy hundreds of trucks
from hydron that it will equip with
self-driving technology
and one more thread I'll throw in there
is they share an investor a really
important investor his name is Charles
Chao he's the chief executive and
chairman of a big Chinese conglomerate
called Cena Corp and he was a critical
backer of too simple and then of hydron
and really the relationship just builds
from there okay so according to people
familiar with the matter there are
government probes into too simple and
this relationship with Hydro has a lot
to do with it can you just break down
what those are yeah Zoe there's a lot
going on here and so there are
investigations by government authorities
from the FBI the SEC and the committee
on foreign investment in the United
States which is often called cypheus in
addition the board of directors at too
simple open an investigation
in July into what too simple was doing
regarding hydron and so we've had these
four concurrent investigations all of
which are ongoing okay so what are they
looking at primarily government
authorities are looking at whether too
simple improperly financed hydron and
transferred technology to hydron and
they are looking at it from the
perspective of did too simple fail to
make the Securities filings and this
disclosures that are required of them
whenever they have a so-called related
party transaction
so it's really being looked at it as a
potential Financial crime and the FBI in
particular is concerned about
shareholders into simple being defrauded
if shouty how and others are too simple
willingly gave technology to a Chinese
competitor because obviously that
technology and the proprietary nature of
that technology is what makes or made
too simple so valuable to them
companies that about these
investigations well the company told us
that they were not aware of any FBI or
SEC investigations the company said it's
been in discussions with cypheus it's
also notable that cepheus had another
investigation into two simple last year
and it has been in communication with
two simple since then and so too simple
said it has discussions with cepheus but
it declined to comment on the substance
of those discussions and it declined to
comment on the board investigation now
we know the board investigation LED them
to fire the CEO which they announced on
Monday he was also their Chief
technology officer the president and the
chairman of the board what did the
company say about why it took that step
they said that they fired him because
what they had found so far in their
ongoing investigation
was that too simple had shared
confidential information with hydron and
the board didn't know about this
incident and it had shared confidential
information with hydron prior to
entering into a business deal with
hydron
in addition the Securities filing said
that the board discovered that several
two simple employees had worked for
hydron and gotten paid for their work
while also being on the payroll at too
simple and I will say that shouty posted
on LinkedIn a lengthy statement in which
he says that he denies any suggestion of
wrongdoing he has nothing to hide and he
stands by all of his actions and
decisions regarding too simple is isn't
there a bigger picture about competition
between the US and China here yeah
that's really the key backdrop to the
Zoe the United States and China have
both named the technology that underpins
self-driving Vehicles which is
artificial intelligence as critical
technology to National Security for
military purposes as well as for
economic competitiveness in September
President Biden issued an executive
order which was aimed at improving the
scrutiny of foreign investment in U.S
companies building critical technology
it also specifies that the technology
for hydrogen-powered vehicles which is
what hydron claims it's making is key to
the United States national security so
you have this issue where both China and
the US have openly declared repeatedly
that this technology is essential to
them both are working like crazy to
develop it and now we have a situation
where the company that had been
considered the lead and self-driving
Trucking
has a very questionable future we don't
really know what's going to happen next
to this company that has already been
through a lot of turmoil and now faces
what is probably the biggest challenge
of its existence all right I guess we'll
just have to wait and see a little bit
that's our reporter Heather Somerville
thanks for joining us Heather thanks Zoe
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign